I want to give you some background on
this next story I'm going to talk about
a lot of people have been emailing me
saying David you know what you've
identified as Donald Trump's lack of
comfort in reading may actually be part
of a broader cognitive decline that
Donald Trump might be experiencing some
kind of early stage dementia or
Alzheimer's and that that may actually
be what's behind the erratic behavior
the obfuscation the weird rants with
with very limited seemingly limited
vocabulary and I received a blog post
yesterday from a blogger who goes by the
name of the neuro critic who has
outlined the case quite specifically for
Donald Trump's suffering from some kind
of cognitive decline I'm going to
present the information to you and see
what you think okay Alzheimer's disease
and other forms of dementia involve
symptoms that are sort of under the
umbrella of be called neurodegenerative
and they develop over time and typically
get worse over time this includes
forgetfulness trouble finding words
those are often the first symptoms to
develop before more more serious forms
of dementia set in we know that Ronald
Reagan was diagnosed with full-blown
Alzheimer's in 1994 George HW Bush
senior is almost 93 and is still very
cognitively sharp for his age and a
study looked at transcripts of press
conference is given by Ronald Reagan and
George HW Bush during their presidencies
and this was not speeches written by
someone else because that's just reading
this is their sort of original
off-the-cuff dialogue with reporters and
it looked at some specific factors how
many unique words are being used in
other words how broad is the vocabulary
the frequency of nonspecific nouns words
like thing something anything as well as
filler words like unwell so basically
actually and then also what are called
low image ability words like get give go
have and do reagan's use of unique words
significantly declined over his
presidency which correlates with what we
now know was going on with his
Alzheimer's which is he had Alzheimer's
and
was getting worse compared to George HW
Bush that didn't happen
George HW Bush's cognitive state as we
now know was not declining during his
presidency and you didn't see the
decline of unique words used so that
sort of the basis in fact as a frame of
reference and according to Ron Reagan
who is of course Ronald Reagan's son but
ironically an atheist and a liberal
yeah he's commented that he's seen his
dad experience some early signs of
dementia even when he was serving as
president and we now is sort of in
retrospect are able to identify that
through analyses like the one I'm
talking about here and over the course
of his presidency Reagan increased his
use of these nonspecific nouns of filler
words George HW Bush didn't do this and
that all makes sense
Reagan and Bush were pretty close in age
during their respective presidencies so
the idea here is that it might be
possible to predict a president
potential for dementia based on an
analysis of how they speak that gets us
to President Donald Trump and it seems
like the conversations about Trump and
mental instability focus around oh he
has a narcissistic personality disorder
and he may have that right you have the
delusions of grandeur the self flattery
the arrogance his superiority complex
his need for admiration from others but
some notable psychiatrists including
Alan Francis said you know Donald Trump
doesn't strictly fit the criteria for
narcissistic personality disorder we
could say Trump is colloquially
narcissistic but that narcissistic
personality disorder may well not be an
accurate diagnosis but instead let's
consider Donald Trump's cognitive state
and this is something that fewer people
are thinking about in terms of Trump
I'll remind you that at the age of 70
Trump is the oldest person ever elected
president let's listen to Trump speak
now that we're going to pay attention to
what we know about Reagan and Bush
paying attention to Trump's use of words
filler words nonspecific nouns words
like thing anything nothing
remember this clip from just a few weeks
ago you know what uranium is right thing
called nuclear weapons and other things
like lots of things are done with
uranium including some bad things
nobody talks about that I didn't do
anything for Russia I've done nothing
for Russia six instances of variants of
the word thing in only 15 seconds and
this isn't really cherry-picking I mean
during that press conference Donald
Trump used the expression
very very 20 times and he said the word
thing over 100 times
compare that to a clip of Donald Trump
speaking when he was 42 years old now
I'm not going to say Trump was exactly
eloquent when he was 42 years old but
there's a notable difference in his
ability to express himself take a look
at this well it's going to be very
interesting I think I think that
probably George Bush has an advantage in
terms of the election I think that
probably people would say that he's got
like that little edge in terms of the
incumbency etcetera etc but so Donald
Trump's father suffered from Alzheimer's
and family history is a factor with
Alzheimer's and according to the Mayo
Clinic the earliest signs of Alzheimer's
or dementia can include mood swings
irritability make your own judgment
about that lack of restraint which is
pretty obvious I mean remember Donald
Trump mocking a journalist with a
disability for instance doesn't exactly
communicate restraint put another poor
guy you got to see this guy I don't know
what I said ah I don't remember he's
don't like I don't remember I'll maybe
that's what I said watch the YouTube
videos of young Donald Trump and imagine
the 40-something year old Trump doing
arm flapping things where he makes fun
of a guy with a disability hard to
imagine Trump has definitely changed
over time in some way and this is a
totally different Trump making things up
another factor that you often start to
see in the early signs of Alzheimer's or
dementia we have no shortage of examples
there Donald Trump just as one example
tweeting in addition to winning the
electoral college in a landslide I won
the popular vote if you deduct the
millions of people who voted illegally
no evidence of that just making stuff up
disjointed speech when Trump was being
interviewed by David Muir Trump was
asked about the voter fraud claims and
Trump answered by saying quote let me
sure and I
and I'm very and I mean it but just so
you know it was supposed to be a
confidential meeting they turned it into
not a number two
the conversation lasted for about a
minute they made it somebody said it was
like 25% of the it wasn't it was hardly
even discussed another very common early
sign of dementia is trouble balancing
you might remember when Donald Trump was
at the White House holding hands with
British prime minister Theresa May the
Daily Mail asked a source close to the
president why he did this and they said
Oh Donald Trump sometimes has trouble
balancing the source actually said quote
Trump has a morbid fear of stairs and
slopes he hates Heights where you can
see the ground or sharp inclines he
particularly dislikes staircases here's
video from the incident that I'm
referring to and as you'll see Donald
Trump coming out and then it looks like
there's a couple steps or an incline and
he holds Teresa Mae's hand obviously we
are not qualified to make a diagnosis
neither would anyone else who's not
examined Donald Trump in person but
there are a number of signs here Pat
that are definitely concerning it's
possible too that the emperor just
doesn't have any clothes because we've
known for a while that he's not the most
eloquent person he is the vocabulary of
a fourth grader so Elmo spaghetti was a
vocabulary of a fourth grader it's
possible that behind this means he has
some much more sophisticated vocabulary
but at least publicly he yes he speaks
like a fourth grader well he says he's
like a smart person to believe that he's
similar to a smart person in some sense
but not actually one yeah send me your
thoughts on this okay we're going to
link to the source blog post here and
you can take a look at all the evidence
yourself